everyone's Peter Brown standing in for
Miguel concepción for his review of
Forza horizon 3 as with every well-made
open world sports our horizons three
lands are rife with distractions in this
semi fictionalized setting of South East
Australia every mile between you and
your presumptive Waypoint can feature
dozens of detours before you know it
you're up five levels 1 million credits
richer and you still haven't reached the
music festival that you meant to reach
an hour ago
developer playground games expands on
the previous games regional hubs
glorified garages and showrooms to buy a
new car and turns them into their own
festivals imagine a multi-stage music
gathering like Coachella or Glastonbury
except you have to drive five miles to
get to the next closest tent whereas the
last games main campaign path was
focused on tournaments for star rising
three emphasizes gaining followers in
order to open up more events upwards
with 50 per region when you combine all
four regions you have a selection of
events that rivals the huge burnout
paradise while forces Australia doesn't
feel notably larger than forces Europe
this new locale has the previous one
beat on the sheer number of things to do
the now three year old dravite our
system has proven itself as a viable
alternative to traditional ketchup or
rubberband AI but surprising about Forza
horizon 3 is the wealth of social
options without your friends real-time
presence leaderboards are old hat as our
forming clubs and racing buddies to
reach 100% completion these familiar
features are now joined with modes that
let you curate your own shareable
championships and special events there's
no worrying of building a track from
scratch instead you dive into the game's
myriad route and destination templates
while also designing a stylized flyer
ports are rez and three takes the
single-player reputation game to its
next evolutionary step with a lesson in
branding 101 it's no joke you have to
complete objectives refer to as PR
stunts once you finish rolling your eyes
and accept it it's a sign of the times
you can look beyond the propagandist
window dressing and simply focus on the
objectives whether it's by stringing
together stunts or executing a single
vehicular feat destination ports are
horizon 3 pummels you with dopamine hits
well beyond traditional races it's not
unheard of to gain a level unlock a perk
expand a festival and obtain a new car
in the span of seconds this can occur at
any time whether you've just completed a
championship or simply avoid a traffic
while jetting down the highway the skill
tree is also tripled in size for this
Australian excursion along with perks
that enhance the ability to get more
perks you can purchase experience points
and earn bonuses that ultimately lead to
new cars this is a series known for
taking reasonable liberties in its real
world locational inspirations for ports
are rising 3 that means being able to
drive from Surfers Paradise to byron bay
in 90 seconds normally a one hour drive
real-world locales like the Kiowa Valley
and the Twelve Apostles also litter this
eastern region of Australia it's a
pleasingly subdued version of the
continent rather than a caricature of it
there's a generous helping of lush
forests and open fields set to the often
gorgeous backdrops of weather in day and
night cycles after tackling
Mediterranean Europe and Colorado to
ship to Australia is fitting for driving
series that has now made room for more
off-road competitions the natural and
predictability of off-road driving is a
stimulating accompaniment to the more
structured asphalt races and you can't
deny the thrill of holding your breath
while barreling through a forest
praying that you thread between trees
that aren't clearly visible until
they're only 5 yards in printing
[Applause]
[Music]
with ports of three turn ten and
playground games affirms a series status
as the driving game for everyone it
speaks to the series broad appeal that
you can devote dozens of hours on a
handful of vehicle classes without ever
sitting inside of a 4x4 all the while
the developers calculated kitchen-sink
designs and a rich reward system
persistently tempt you to explore beyond
your comfort zone whether it's by
granting you a special new car or
reminding you that stunt races can press
over a hundred thousand fans in the game
enhancing your own brand might be a
turn-off but pulling off sickie drips on
a mile-long series of curves makes the
whole PR work worth one
enough wins boss it's somebody off the
Chance kitchen
keep it up
[Applause]